[Music]
welcome patreon people to [ __ ] up news
oh wow no
it's the only show where we share some
[ __ ] up or weird news sometimes it's
[ __ ] weird news sometimes it's [ __ ]
up news can it be both at the same time
today it might be a little bit of both
so
a man
was a man has died in brazil after
jumping into a lake to escape bees only
to be opened by
piranhas god the fact that we're all
laughing yeah that's a good pit bro
[ __ ] out of here yeah dude in brazil bro
that's hilarious this is safe
you got to get away from these [ __ ]
bees man what's the worst death is the
question
yeah that's some looney tune sherry
you're [ __ ] whatever
you grab a straw so you go in the water
and then you [ __ ] get eaten dude this
is tom and jerry there's actually like a
buddhist proverb like this where this
dude he's running away from a tiger and
then he sees a hole and he [ __ ] jumps
in it and when he lands in the hole it's
a pit of snakes
and then i don't know the rest
i don't know the [ __ ] rest of it
someone's gotta help you with this it's
a problem every everybody sounds exactly
the [ __ ] same everybody in china saw
the store they're like no [ __ ]
you [ __ ] idiot no [ __ ] [ __ ]
chinese papa always say run from b die
from
[Laughter]
no [ __ ] [ __ ] of course man you [ __ ]
idiot i know so he was fishing with
friends when he uh fishing for piranhas
with friends
he's like oh i know piranhas are in here
perfect he was fishing with friends and
then they were being chased by bees were
like [ __ ] with the bees that's what i
want to know no no no it was just just
swarming bees came oh [ __ ] and then uh
this [ __ ] [ __ ] he jumps into the lake
and is like basically swarmed by
piranhas oh my god was he the only one
that died he is the only one he's the
only one jumped in the lake his friend
his friend's like whoa just to be a
[ __ ] idiot it was just two bees i
used to uh uh have an illegal fish
business with my buddy and i would sell
see every time he says something dude i
have no idea where he
people say that you lie about your
stories this [ __ ]
fucker's like you know what's funny the
funny thing is david always gets accused
nobody doubts me no never
and it's not until you meet the people
where you're like oh so david was
telling the truth talking about this
yesterday yeah we're like we'll just
randomly meet somebody from like a crazy
david story and it's like oh my god that
that really did happen
and no one questions me ever no it feels
like when i was a hot hot air balloon
salesman
nobody even doubted it i was like yeah
yeah probably but i used to work at
dunder mifflin
but bart can back me up on this i sold
our friend a batch of piranhas sorry
what right you sold your friend what a
batch of piranhas where did you get a
batch of piranhas
so you had to get it from a wholesaler
no okay of course
the wholesaler will typically be
maybe someone who's in the fish business
and in the back of their store or they
have other fishes that they're not the
exotics
yeah and then we knew a family friend
that uh owned a fish store
right by taco bell but it's no longer
there anymore but in the back you know
he had piranhas and all these things and
in the way that they smuggled them as
babies they were small right so you
raise them you grow them and then you
have full-size piranhas to sell and you
have other fishes too that are legal but
anyways piranhas was my [ __ ] i love
selling them because people
love to watch them eat yeah and then and
then so i would sell piranhas and and
the thing is piranhas they don't
actually attack humans as much because
they're really skittish fish they're
scared like i could ice i like doing
this thing where i stuck my hand in the
piranha tank and everyone would be like
oh my god you did that in the [ __ ]
piranha tank and they don't they don't
bite me because they're scared of me
right they're racist they hate japanese
people exactly
but when you
when you throw something
into sushi
[Laughter]
when you throw some goldfish in there
they go [ __ ] crazy how much would you
sell a piranha for yeah what is the
market price man yeah because i would
sell them in batches and [ __ ] but it was
like only a couple bucks what that's
like that's it
per per person so it's like two three
bucks each or whatever how many how many
of these are you selling in a batch
people will buy like 10 sometimes 20
because like it's cool when you buy them
in a in a pack yeah so it has to be
volume yeah yeah yeah yeah but i mean
what you're in high school right so
you're making these in high school dude
what the [ __ ]
it's a it's a high school fishing club
that's what i did piranha salesman is a
high school
illegal put on a salesman you sold okay
you sell weed a little bit x you're
seeing some [ __ ] problems you had a
store bro you're one of one dude no
connection to either one of them
it sounds crazy but it's pretty normal
though back in those days right
no you don't have to have his back on
this yeah
because we're all the same people so
like the wii the ecstasy fire on it
you know the fact that you guys have a
client basically by piranha stolen sound
systems from cars it's all part of the
same thing
illegal [ __ ] yeah like black [ __ ] it's
it's a black mark you guys are the silk
road right here
opening up your coat and then you have
two piranhas on your fingers like this
which one do you want they're all wiggly
oh they're like on the finger i hope i
get a sale
[Laughter]
i'll take four dollars but they're
actually very scared of humans like you
could stick your hand in your scared of
this guy
they were just waiting maybe he was
bleeding all right these guys are also
wild ones
so if you get ones that are in the tank
they breathe they get kind of a little
bit gentler or softer or whatever these
guys are right
they're city piranhas
this gentleman definitely disagrees that
piranhas aren't really deadly to humans
um and the police say that they found uh
his body and he had no face anymore okay
so this is where i wanted to get to
[ __ ] the way piranhas eat this is
it's [ __ ] vicious right so you throw
goldfish in or a bigger fish doesn't
matter
the way that it works is
they they first attack the limbs and the
stomach
yeah they go straight for the stomach
they rip the guts out and then they
start [ __ ] up the fins and things so
as the fish is swimming they're trying
to get away but then they come in
they're like punks that come up and
sucker punch you and run away right so
they come up as a script run rip and run
yeah they rip and run so you'll see
these [ __ ] fish which just guts
dangling while they're still swimming
and i'm like eat the [ __ ] fool like
hold don't just leave them there that's
something awful i think it's slowing
down yeah but then i ended up not liking
egg i wondered like the brazilian guy
was like george said what told me to say
[Music]
[Laughter]
dude who would have [ __ ] thought joe
was the expert on piranhas like this
although out of every anybody in the
room that's probably what i already
guessed maybe ryan i was like
but they're like cowards that's right
they're tough in numbers so if there's
like three piranhas they'll probably
leave you alone a thousand they're not
scared like proud boys in antifa yeah
pretty much
a little insane you know what a timely
reference
hey we're gonna [ __ ] this guy up hey
anybody here oh [ __ ] oh no
you're cool
i was [ __ ] wrong huh
was a swarm of bees or was it like two
or three it really doesn't say it so i
kind of just you know have some fun with
it
you guys watch those um amazon fishing
shows it's called like river giants or
rivers river monsters dude with jeremy's
dude those guys i love that stuff dude
the kind of fish that they get they look
like dude i binge watched that
[ __ ] he has the worst set of
teeth i've ever seen in my life is he
british british is fun what's his name
damn just put river monsters jeremy my
kind of my kind of people
it's like these folklore stuff with
giant catfish like in the amazon or i
think it was in the amazon something
called the arapaima which is like this
huge gigantic scaled armored fish it
kind of looks like a sturgeon that's
like something that he also hunted too
does it have legs arms and legs
literally like the the length of that
table times two it looks like a canoe
it's a freshwater fish too well how do
you [ __ ] catch though fishing
there's another fish that he caught in
africa that looks like a piranha but
it's like 20 times the size of it it's
like a barracuda i think this is the one
i don't know what the yeah this is his
teeth though i got it for his teeth it's
very similar to the
vampire fish that's the that's the one
that fish's teeth look better
yeah they're straighter they're more yes
18 teeth just in the first round what
fish vampire fish is that an underbite
or an overbite i can't really tell
that's a both dude
yeah this [ __ ] oh my [ __ ]
lord god doesn't show the size that is
insane
watch i turn around a picture of a huge
dick
i thought about it i thought about it
that [ __ ] oh my god what is that called
vampire fish and that's just out in the
river
okay you're like scuba diving you see
that what do you do
i [ __ ] punch him in the face dude
[Music]
dude like hanging over your wallet real
quick you're just like oh [ __ ] what
would you do to a fish in the world beat
the [ __ ] out of a fish though hey do you
know how to underwater fight you go like
that
that's like this
have you guys have you guys ever tried
to [ __ ] in us in a in a hot tub yeah of
course
it's the worst thing ever nobody when i
was younger nobody [ __ ] tells you
when you watch those pornos yeah that
[ __ ] water and then [ __ ] juice
doesn't mix yeah it's wonderful
it lubricates it i actually fingered a
girl's butt in a housing one time i'm
not kidding that was probably easier why
but
she wanted it in the butt yeah she asked
for it she's like can you finger my butt
and i was like absolutely
like why did you even don't say this
question make a statement yeah i was
like don't make it unsexy yeah think of
my butt yeah all right
[Music]
you